looks like we're assembled here so we'll
get started
um so again we got the notebooks if you
want to download those
um and also oh I should have mentioned
this um The Notebook requires Seaborn
which as far as I can tell at least when
I tried I I uninstalled and reinstalled
Anaconda drro I didn't get Seaborn so I
had to from command prompt I had to run
pip install Seaborn to get that
um
huh yeah you can also do cond if you
prefer
um e either either cond or pip and stall
will we'll get you there I
theoretically
um so okay so R do you want to stand up
in the back so um this was some of this
material was jointly prepared by me and
I'm Steve Elston and Ronald um Lopez is
in the back and the way we're going to
do this is I'm going to yak and Ronald
is here to help you guys if you get
stuck on something or can't do it I'm
going to try to break this up into like
five or six segments where I'll give you
a little bit of an introduction then
we've got some exercises prepared where
you guys get to try something and you
know give you like a couple you know
four or five minutes to do the little
exercise and you know so we'll go
through it in little pieces like that so
hopefully it'll be more interesting and
interactive I mean I find for me in
tutorials or when I'm learning stuff the
only thing I remember like two weeks
later is the stuff I did not what
somebody told me in a lecture but maybe
that's just me I don't know um so
um do you want to say some introduction
about yourself
Ronald you're okay all right I can I can
introduce Ronald too um so I'm a
principal consultant at a company called
quante analytics a very small boutique
data science consultancy I teach and I
also my my Moonlight job is I teach data
science at the University of Washington
and I've have some O'Reilly Publications
and have created some etex courses um
and as you can tell I've been around for
a while doing data science since before
it was called data science back when we
actually called it statistics um but you
know times change got to keep up and um
Ronald's a um research analyst um with
the uh San Jose Evergreen Community
College system and he's also active with
the California
Institution institutional research board
and um so enough about that so let's get
started with the actual material here um
no actually let me say a few more
introductory things so data set is one I
if you guys are sort of new to data
science or whatever there's this pretty
amazing um University of California
Irvine machine learning repository has
lots of data sets some of them are
really great some of them are like super
weird um and you know that or there's
like the Kagel site there's a bunch of
places you can grab data set that's to
to just try stuff out or or if you're
like me Teach stuff and you need some
exam some good examples um
so one thing I'll mention about this
data is you'll notice it's a little
quaint in terms of automobile prices and
even some automobile companies that I
don't think exist anymore but it's from
1985 so um the data is a bit antique but
the the methods we're going to use
aren't so that's good um and
you can read all this but to me
visualization is one of those core data
science skills um there's a there's a
tendency that we all have to want to get
in and see some numbers or build a model
or do something like that but honestly
if you haven't looked at the data if you
don't have a feel for what what the
columns are and how they relate say to
your label or what weirdness there might
be in the relationship between them
maybe outliers maybe features that are
just completely collinear that don't
really tell you anything
um you know you really are missing the
boat so along with sort of cleanup and
figuring out how your data works and
modeling you should be going back and
forth and doing as much visualization as
you can figure out and it's it's all
about having you know da real world data
that you're going to do for money is
is inherently complex like if it was
easy nobody would pay you to do it right
so so you need to create different views
of the data different ways to think
about putting it together and generally
that means multiple you know you'll do
multiple different types of charts
you'll try different combinations of
which variables go on those charts
things like that um and you get into
this fundamental problem that you know
we're all looking at screens or or
whatever so the projection surface we
always visualize data on is
two-dimensional and that's a real
limitation you know we can't maybe
someday we'll have VR systems that we
can walk through you know 18 dimensions
of data or something but we're not there
right now we're stuck in two-dimensional
space and and one of a lot of what I'm
going to show you here is how
to best use that two-dimensional space
how to get the most information without
and and and a word of caution which I'll
repeat several times probably is don't
try to get too much onto that I've I've
been to some talks in fact one lately um
by a speaker who I won't name um a few
weeks ago who I you absolutely could not
I and maybe he understood his charts but
you could see from the slack ja looks in
the audience that nobody else had any
idea about all the subtle differences in
colors shim symbols dot dotted lines you
know I don't know what all he had going
on there and it was completely you know
inscrutable so so don't overdo it you
know there's there's ways around this
sometimes it just means you got to look
at a lot more plots or do some some
other things um just a historic note I'm
not recommending anybody run out and
read these books unless you're kind of
interested in the history so way back
you know go back to like you know almost
prehistoric times for data science um in
the 1960s and early
70s statistics because there was no data
science in those days was all about
models and in fact like for me as an
undergraduate in the 70s looking you
know we had to learn how to
prove things about the central limit
theorem or something that was what a
stats class was you didn't actually look
at data as crazy as that seems right I
mean like how can you do stats without
data but they that's what that's how it
was done and John W Tui who was you know
one of the truly great minds of data
analysis ever um started saying well
wait guys we got to look at the data
don't just like start building all these
models and doing all this Theory but
what is actually in the data and he
published a number of papers um and and
kind of pulled it together in this
really groundbreaking book exploratory
data analysis
1977 so that to me is sort of the you
know the the T equals zero time of of
exploratory data analysis when that book
hit the hit the
shelves um so spool forward almost 20
years and William Cleveland Bill
Cleveland who I had the the privilege to
work with um when he was at Bell Labs he
started working about this problem I was
just talking about like like we only
have two Dimensions to project our data
onto and you know believe it or not in
those days a lot of it had to do with
you know actually like pen plotting on
paper but regardless whether it's on a
screen from a web page or plot it with
actual ink on a paper um you still have
this problem you're projecting onto 2D
surfaces so Bill had been thinking
deeply about this problem for 10 15
years and he published again another
pioneering book called visual izing data
in the early
9s
um and so what's the outline of what
we're going to do here um we're going to
first off just go through because this
is a a course an introductory tutorial
here that's how we build it so we're
just going to talk about what are some
basic plot types and there's a lot more
than we can cover um but at least I want
to get everybody on the page where
you've at least built a few basic plots
and you know look at oh I should point
out there's also so yeah here the
resources so there's like this pandas
visualization tutorial a Seaborn
visualization tutorial and then matplot
livebe also and and this one's par has a
lot there's a lot of Rich stuff here
there's videos there's books and
articles and some tutorials there's a
lot more you can do with this than we
can cover in 90 minutes for sure I mean
people spend you know literally careers
researching visualization so all right
so the first thing we got to do is load
the data set and there's a couple of
weirdnesses with this data which is that
the missing values were coded as a text
question
mark and also that um the numeric
columns were coded as text so we have to
go through find all the question marks
turn them to a numpy n
you know get rid
of you could do various things we could
interpolate we could backfill if you
heard key shor's talk he went through
that there's only I think 10 of them out
of about 205 so we're just going to
remove those and not worry about the
lost data at this point and then we got
to convert everything to numeric so go
ahead and run that cell so if you don't
know you can just run a cell you
probably guys probably know that but
just click the Run cell and hopefully it
worked
hopefully it won't take too long or die
here that would be
bad not sure why it's taking so long
anybody else having problems loading it
or is it okay okay all right oh okay it
worked I guess just sleepy computer comp
and we can look at the head of the data
frame just to get a feel for what's
there and there's this actually
originally this data set had to do with
insurance losses that's why there's the
symbolizing and normalized losses column
which we're largely going to ignore but
you can see there's like the make of the
car the fuel type the aspiration that is
whether it's standard or Turbo the
number of doors you know a bunch of
common characteristics of cars some
characteristics of their
engines uh um and there's mileage and
then the price of the car so just for
point of exercise here we're just going
to focus on though we were exploring to
build a model so we could figure out the
prices of cars there's there is actually
a real there can be real problems with
this for example you know like there's
this estimate for Zillow for Real Estate
right where they're trying to estimate
the price of a house based on various
characteristics so this is kind of like
the the car the 1985 car um version of
that so and we can just look at some of
summary of some of the numeric columns
and just get a feel for there's a wide
range of of values here you know from um
the wheel base the length you see
they're just different ranges of
variables um I
didn't so that's just and you can look
at that more if you want but you can
just get a get an idea of what the you
know and
then the Min the max the quartiles so
and that's using by the way the pandas
describe so let's get started with some
flot so so to me the the plot that I use
most that's kind of a fundamental plot
is the scatter plot and we'll do a line
plot and then some more plots where we
look at sort of distributions bar plots
histograms box plots kernel density
estimation and violin plots so there's
lots of um plots for that so a scatter
plot pretty much I'm sure you're
familiar with that you're plotting X
against y you're looking at the
distribution oh one thing if you are
running in a notebook or any kind of
IPython environment um and you want
stuff to display in line you need this
magic command matplot Li in line you
know with the percent or else stuff will
either not display or display in another
window or something like that so we're
just going to make a really simple so
the way this works so this is we have a
pandas data frame here called Auto
underbar prices okay and then I've got a
plot method on that and I can say what
kind of plot I want scatter in this case
there's a whole bunch of and if you look
at that tutorial um that I have a
reference to earlier you'll see um where
that is and I'm just going to do City
miles per G gon against price
okay and there you have it you can see
it's not really a linear relationship
it's pretty curvy and there's some other
points out here so already we're and
then there's this cluster of kind of
high priced low fuel efficiency cars
here and a cluster of pretty cheap
remarkably High fuel efficiency see cars
over there so already we're seeing some
Curious aspects of this data set maybe
we can figure out what that all that's
about um and in here if you go back and
look at the notebook later I've kind of
given you the recipe for how I do stuff
um so we're going to so the next thing
is we're going to use matplot Li so I'm
going to import matplot li. pyplot as
PLT and I'm going to define a figure of
a certain size 10x 10 and I'm I'm going
to Define just one axis at this point
within that figure you see how that
works and so now we can plot that make
that same plot but we do it assigning an
axis set of axes and and also we can now
assign attributes see I've got ax.
settitle so I give it a main title label
Etc now to me and maybe it's because I
also teach data science a plot
without um without prop ER labels is
utterly useless and and honestly if
you're going to another reason to to
learn visualization is as data
scientists we want to have impact we
want people to to pay attention to our
results we want people to take action on
our results that's where we deliver
value and if you go to a management
presentation and show a bunch of plots
with no access labels and no
titles you know you the um you know
executive time you know attention span
is going to make a 2-year-old look like
a a laser focus you know so you're
you're doomed so always make sure you
have good good access labels and there's
nothing new on this plot it's just you
can see I made it bigger so we can kind
of see it better well maybe you guys can
cuz I I blew up my screen so and we've
got proper labels but I did that by
using this by creating an axis that I
could ass sign attributes too so that's
the the key Point here and then a line
plot as you can imagine is pretty
similar so first off um I'm just going
to create a new data frame where we have
an X
AIS and a y variable that's just the
square so it's just going to be 100
points on the X and the Y and we're just
going to create a data frame for
those using the pandas do dataframe
method
okay and then again using that same
recipe we can now plot but notice I
don't have to say what kind is
because Panda's plotting the default
kind is a line that's the def default
method if it doesn't know any better
it'll make a line plot so if you get
sometimes you get really cooky results
because you forgot to say the kind if
you see something that looks like a
bunch of worms having a wrestle wring
match or something it's probably because
you forgot to say the kind you really
want it so let me run that and there's
nothing too surprising here right um
it's just a just a plot of half a
parabola um as you'd
expect okay so now you got now it's your
turn so um you've seen a couple of
examples so try to plot engine size
against price we looked at cities miles
per gallon against plot
try to make the Figure 8 by 8 instead of
10x 10 and and make sure you give it
your figure a meaningful title and axis
labels okay so we'll give you guys just
a couple like three M that's pretty easy
so we'll give you like three minutes to
do that okay and raise your hand if you
feel like you're not quite there or some
problem and you're welcome to work you
know with the people next to you or
whatever
oh I suppose everybody knows right to
make a new cell below there you just
insert a cell below like that so you can
have a cell that you can cut and you can
just cut and paste some of my code in
there and edit it and
then just run it with this run
here
so I should have said that before
sorry oh oh um it's at a do you have it
Ronald Ronald will help
you I found it in GI how do I run it
with
do you not do you not have do you have
Jupiter
install huh well if you if you installed
the did you install Anaconda H yeah I
did okay well you should be able to so
go to your where you have anaconda and
look
forer
machine I don't think I have well yeah
so go ahead and if you want to install
it on that machine or or if you just
want to follow on on the GitHub you'll
see there's also the just static HTML or
work with other people at your
table it it should just um when you
start Jupiter if you start it should
just be there right when you start like
do do import
cbns I
started oh oh yeah no you want to
probably not because you probably
started the colel didn't I don't know it
just puts it in the
directory
all right um success failure somewhere
in
between still
working all
right well you guys can get back to that
later we'll just we have to push on here
so we're going to start talking about
plots that
um where you look at a um a distribution
of something and kind of the the
granddaddy of all those is the bar plot
so the bar plot C has counts on the
vertical axis and categories on the
horizontal axis and
um but the the thing is with if you're
using Panda's plotting you have to have
count
right the it it the the the plotting
method
itself doesn't know how to make those
counts so that's a common mistake where
you try to make a bar plot out of some
categorical variable and you get some
you know
long traceback of all sorts of errors
that seem cryptic and that so so
basically you wind up or the way I can
you can do it that's pretty easy is I'm
just going to make a new data frame and
I'm going to do this for the make which
is the you know like the manufacturer of
the car so I'm just going to do one
column and and pandas has a value
underbar counts method so let me just
run that you'll
see so there so it's a data frame it has
an in so notice that the the make now is
the
index of the data frame it's not a
column that's the
index and and then it only has one
actual of data which is the count so you
can see like there's 32 Toyotas 18
Nissans and then down to one
Mercury
um all right so so that's the important
sort of trick to know to make a bar plot
everything else is pretty much so this
is the same recipe we used before except
notice I've got counts. plot. bar now I
could have done counts. plot and then
kind equals bar that it it you know
there's you can do it either way I
decided to show you guys both ways um
not to confuse you just to show you that
it it most of the time works either way
so I'm going to go ahead and do this
here
and you can see yeah here we got Toyota
oh notice one cool thing when it does
counts the default is to give you an
ordered list from the largest to the
smallest which is nice because when I go
to make you know you often want see that
in a bar plot um you know you got Toyota
Nissan Etc down to one Mercury car so
you see the most important or the most
numerous I maybe it's not the most
important depending on your analysis but
at least the most numerous type um but
you could do some you know we could sort
this we could sort this by the index of
that that new data frame we created and
um you know maybe we want to do it by
alphabetical or maybe we have something
even more complicated where we want to
do it by you know is it a European
manufacturer a North American
manufacturer an Asian manufacturer I
mean whatever whatever makes sense right
but just as a default it's nice that it
comes out by from largest to smallest
now a
histogram is virtually the same idea
except it's for a continuous variable so
notice this is a categorical variable um
Toyota isn't a larger or smaller number
than a Nissan or a Honda or whatever
it's just a
category
so but if we have numeric variable like
in this case engine size a histogram is
like a barplot except it has a range of
numeric values that are equally spaced
and you can I didn't do it here but if
you look at the arguments if you do like
the help pages are really good for these
things if you look at pandas do if you
like use your favorite search engine
pandas do dataframe do um h. plot. his
or something like that you'll find that
method and you'll see yeah you can set
the number of bins and things like that
um there's a bunch of arguments so so
this and again got my titles and access
labels so let me just do that and I'm
just taking all the defaults in this
case we'll get to doing fancier things
with a histogram here in a bit but so we
can see it's actually kind of
interesting um notice that the average
car of 1985 these are in cubic in that's
obviously because this is an American
data set so it uses non-metric units um
but you can see there's a heavy skew
that cars tend to have much smaller
engines and there's a few cars with
really tiny engines and a few cars that
are way out here with these ginormous
engines so we've already learned just by
looking at this histogram of engine size
we can see there's there's kind of some
interesting stuff going on just with the
engine size of these
cars another way you can look at sort of
relative frequency or size is with a box
plot so I mentioned Tuki in his 1977
book at the beginning of the the talk
here so this is a t a plot that Tui came
up with um in
1970 so it's been around for a while um
and the nice thing about that is you can
do two like we'll do engine size again
but I've got
another um column here fuel type so you
can do buy equals fuel type so that's
like if you're used to SQL that's the
same as a group buy operation and SQL
just that buy and you know the rest of
this is just following our same recipe
there's nothing I haven't slipped in
anything new there just yet we'll get
there and you can see if you look at my
Axis labels I got fuel type so I have
diesel cars I've grouped all the diesel
cars and I've grouped all the gas or
gasoline cars and you can see the range
of engine sizes here so how do you read
a box plot so the Red Bar some it
depends on what plotting system you're
using pandas plots it's a red bar
sometimes it's a dark thick bar whatever
the bar is in the middle of the Box
however that's displayed that's the
median value of that so you can see you
can see the median gas diesel engine is
somewhat larger than the median um
gasoline engine but then the upper inter
quartile and the lower inter cortile are
what make up the box above and below
that bar so so this the inter quartile
range which is these two inner quartiles
is just that whole box and so if I give
this an eyeball I would say yeah there's
it does look like
generally diesel engine cars have
slightly larger engine displacements
than gasoline cars but also I would look
and say well yeah but the inter quartile
range overlaps so much that I'm not sure
that's a significant difference you know
maybe it really doesn't matter maybe
it's just a fluke of a few cars having
bigger engines or something clearly
there's a bit of skew too with diesels
you see that there's kind of a the inner
quartile range upper and lower look
about the same here but notice how it's
more compressed for
diesels so well we we'll we'll press on
maybe we'll find something else okay so
I hope everybody was able to install
Seaborn um and I just in the notebook I
give you guys I just repeat that
direction um what was the what was the
verdict on guy people who did you
restart to get it to go with Jupiter or
did it I relaunched it but it still
didn't still didn't work oh has anybody
else tried to load Seaborn
or well we'll see if this works for you
guys so um so Seaborn is the other
plotting package which I hope you guys
can
run it's going to be a bit of a problem
if it if there's some glitch here um do
you have any idea Ronald why that why
some people are having trouble getting
it to start start in their
Jupiter huh had to create a virtual
environment to get work oh you had to
create a on on a Mac you had to do a
virtual environment
oh I don't have I'm not a one of the
cool kids I don't have a Mac so I don't
know
initially so it worked better with cond
for you than pip yeah because my um I
realized my IPython um was actually kind
of installed and I I go back and forth
between oh okay oh so okay so she's
saying if she had installed IPython with
cond and installed installed Seaborn
then with cond rather than pip and that
worked better
um I I had install well on Windows I had
installed Anaconda the whole Anaconda
stack with cond uh and then used pip and
that worked fine too so H
uhoh yeah I I wish the Anaconda I don't
know if anybody's from Continuum here
but it would be really nice if they put
this package I I don't know why maybe
it's just something that they haven't
gotten to yet but it's it's it's newer
it's kind of the newer some of the newer
cooler plots are in in Seaborn which is
why we're us trying to use it hopefully
we can use it so the basics of Seaborn
are you can set like a a style which is
kind of the background that you're going
to plot against and in this case I just
picked the simplest one like white Grid
it's just a white background with a some
grid lines on it you can there's lots of
arguments you can do and I we had a
reference up at the beginning of the
notebook to um the seab seabo has some
pretty nice tutorial examples you can go
through um
so it's it's pretty well documented it
is we have discovered um it's because
it's a newer package not everything
works consistently quite the way you
would think so there sometimes you think
there should be an argument um and there
isn't or it doesn't quite work or
something like that so it's not it's not
as bulletproof as some of the older
python plotting stuff but it's worth
messing with just because it's got some
nice facilities like in this case
so I'm going to do what's a kernel
density estimation plot KDE plot for the
engine size hopefully not every
hopefully other people can do this
too anybody anybody having any luck or
is it just some luck okay a few few
positive responses okay anybody like
just crashing and burning completely on
this
no
okay so okay well seems like we've
gotten over that hurdle I was a little
worried about that introducing Seaborn
into a tutorial like this where it's a
thing that you have to install on the
Fly and hope it works so what's the idea
so so we looked at you know box plots we
looked at the histogram so the kernel
density estimation plot is basically
it's a local
regression um that's a nonlinear
regression um and so like if you let's
just go back and refresh our minds on
the histogram so remember the histogram
was pretty skewed to the left and then
we had these outliers out here um for
really big engine displacement
cars and so a smooth kind of smooth
regression view of that you can see yeah
that looks right see it's a pretty
skewed to the left and then you got some
little humps out here which are these
cars with anomalously large engine
displacement so it's a very nice way to
present a smoother view than a
histogram and honestly you know it
depends what you're doing there there's
you can't say KD plots are better than
histograms or vice versa it's like well
what are you trying to show why are you
trying to show it um it's just another
tool in your box um when you're doing
this so we can also then extend the
recipe just as we did with the Panda's
plotting we can define a figure again
we're using this is matplot live.
pyplot so which we loaded earlier so
Define a
figure Define our axis here again just
set our white grid
background and the the new thing is here
we got ax equals ax so we've so we're
plotting this caborn plot lot now on
this figure with this axis that we've
defined and because we've defined which
axis we're set of axes I should say
we're doing this on I can use like ax.
set title ax. set X label y Etc just as
I did for the pandas
plot and let me run that and so just as
advertised I get a bigger plot I have my
title I have my Axis labels I will warn
you not every Seaborn plotting method
will take ax as a argument I don't know
why it's a little Annoying inconsistency
it's probably just people haven't gotten
to it you know there's only so many
contributors doing so much and they
probably all have day job so but this
one you know for most plot types it
works really well as you can see we've
got a pretty nice plot with nice labels
and all that
okay and then another plot
what was the point of
this oh so we can do a
two-dimensional KDE plot that that's is
one of the advantages like the
one-dimensional plot in the
histogram are often interchangeable they
may or may not show you any additional
information but there's no I mean people
like if you look at the icky Graphics in
Excel you'll see they try to do a
two-dimensional histogram but I find
them quite at best inscrutable and at
worse misleading but if you do a
two-dimensional KDE plot see I can do
engine size versus price because I have
a two-dimensional surface right so
everything else is oh and I the cmap is
just the color map that I'm using um I
just we'll talk about pallets a little
bit in a bit here so but the big change
here is oh and if you're new to pandas
notice that I it's a it's a list within
the so the square brackets the outer
square brackets here are the subset
operator in pandas the inner square
brackets are defining a python list so
there's there's you got to have if
you're doing several columns that you're
subsetting from pandas by name you got
to have both sets of brackets and
they're not they're not redundant
they're not doing the same thing at
all and there we've got it oops
there we go so you see it's kind of a
contour plot of density and so that's
that's interesting now we've learned
something new remember we we had seen
the skew that most cars had pretty small
engine sizes but we also see that most
cars are actually for on the inexpensive
end of the spectrum because remember
there's 1985 prices so I don't think
there's any new cars you could get
nowadays that are around
$88,000
um maybe maybe a bicycle but
um anyway so you can see that that
there's a distinct skew in the whole
data set toward inexpensive cars with
small
engines is there a way to make it
tighter like the grid to the 2D plot you
see that there is a lot of space Oh H so
the question is is there a way to like
not have all this white space I I don't
think so because they're actually are
cars out here it's just that they're
below they're so low density that
they're below that lowest Contour um
there may be an option actually I'd have
to research it you can manually change
the X liit yeah that's true you can set
XY limits when you set up the axes the
other thing I was going to say is I
think there's an argument to the KDE
plot where for the 2D you can actually
say to show the outliers that are you
know below that lowest Contour
level or you could just man you know you
could actually lay another plot on top
of this you can layer plots right so you
could layer onto that same axis of an XY
scatter plot of the outlier
cars um so yeah so either way like he
said you can you can manually set the XY
x-axis and y- axis limits that's not too
hard or if it was me I guess I'd try to
actually show where where are those
outlier cars cuz there are cars out out
there they're just below that lowest
contour line but that's a great question
so finally a plot that isn't used a lot
but I actually think is very cool as a
violin plot and there's nothing new
again in our recipe here
um we're just going to do it's kind of
like the box plot in terms of arguments
we're going to do X's x and x in this
case is going to be like a group by and
Y is engine size which is the same thing
recall we did with the box plots when we
did the side by-side box plots and
everything else is pretty much what I
just showed
you and so what's a violin plot the you
can see this one almost does well maybe
it looks more like a a mandolin but it
kind of looks like a violin I guess um
this one looks like a broken violin but
the point is it's like a his it combines
some of the nice features of a histogram
with some of the nice features of a box
plot and you can
see the the median is showing as a DOT
here the inner quartile range is showing
as this black bar so there's all the
attributes of a box plot but then
there's like I I should have said not a
histogram a KDE plot then here's the
smooth density curves and now you start
seeing some real differences between
Diesel and gasoline cars all these big
engine cars that are sort of our
outliers all turn out to be gasoline
there are no you know really huge diesel
engines here the diesel are in a pretty
tight range and they're fairly uniformly
distributed compared to the gasoline
cars so just by doing this different
view with a different kind of plot we've
just learned two really interesting
thing so I think okay so now um we're
going to talk about aesthetic so we've
been so a plot Aesthetics can be I mean
Aesthetics sounds like something it's
just optional makes it look pretty and
yeah you can do that and you see that in
a lot of awful looking business Graphics
where people use colors for no reason
just because they think that makes their
plot their PowerPoint look pretty or
something but Aesthetics also can bring
forth important information because you
know as you've seen the mo the we've we
haven't managed to display in any of
these plots so far more than two
dimensions of data
right cuz we're stuck on a two Di
dimensional surface as I said before so
how do we start getting a more
Dimensions well we could use Aesthetics
we can use color transparency you can't
transparency I'll show you why why you
should worry about that we could use
marker size and marker
shape and there's a lot of almost every
plot type has plot specific Aesthetics
that are I'll just show a few examples
it's like innumerable possible things
but let's look at
color so
typically with color you can see we're
going to do a plot here SN s so it's a
again a caborn plot SNS dolm plot um LM
plot if if you
don't have this well it's off my scale
here but maybe I can scroll over no okay
well trying to make this big for you
guys anyway there's a thing about not to
show the regression the default is to
show a regression line which can be
useful right I chose in this case to set
that to false which you guys can see I
hope on your versions but I can't see I
also picked this pallet this um because
the default pallet you can try it
without that pallet argument you'll see
it's it's a shade of blue and green that
are almost identical that's the default
I I couldn't at least on my computer I
could hardly tell the difference Without
Really squinting so we're going to do
City miles per gallon versus price and
we're going to do fuel type is What's
called the Hue argument so again Hue is
like a group by argument and then it
takes two colors from the pallet and
displays them okay so we'll be able to
see gasoline and diesel
cars and because I picked this opt this
optional pallet and if you look at the
the
Seaborn
um um tutorials you'll see there's a
whole section on different like they
give you examples of all the pallets
they Supply and then there's like a
whole other section if you want to you
know be hardcore and build your own
pallets for some special purpose it's an
extensible pallet system which is cool
um but you know it's going to be a lot
of work you better have a good reason
before you commit the time on that I I
generally haven't ever found that need
but you know maybe so so remember when
we looked at this we had this group
group of cars up here we had this group
of cars down here and we had some kind
of cars that were out by themselves away
from this main group or cluster well it
turns out these now you can see very
clearly these cars are the diesel cars
and they they tend to be more expensive
for a given fuel efficiency so by adding
this third dimension to my plot by using
a plot
aesthetic I've brought forth
an interesting relationship here that
for the amount of fuel efficiency I get
I have to spend more to get the
equivalent diesel
car and I suppose if the Volkswagen if
we poll poted I don't know what
emissions or something it would be off
the chart too but that's another story
um
so now we're going to get into something
a little more complicated
how do you take control of a lot of
these Aesthetics and this gets to be
difficult
because there's
limitations in like
Seaborn um for example you
can't change the marker shape and the
marker color independently maybe maybe
like I said maybe someday they'll get to
that um but I if you can I've never
figured it out and I've tried so this is
a fair amount of code here I'm sorry but
you can see it's just my imports oh
patch patches is to make like a legend
okay so there's a matplot live. patches
which is a general purpose Legend um if
you have like swatches of color so
literally patches of color um and so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
again Define a figure and Define an axis
and I'm going to do just manually a
group by you could you know you could do
it you could use Group by um I'm just
because we only have two classes here
I'm just going to do it with inline code
either gas or
diesel and um when you do these group
buys
Panda's plotting is very does some very
user hostile things if you give it a
empty data frame so I always check
before I plot it that the shape that the
the row dimension of the shape the zero
dimension is greater than zero even if
it's one it works but if it's
zero it's bad news and then so I've
set I I pick a
column I have the a I have the Y the X
and I'm going to make it dark blue and
red and then you can see the all this
code is building the the the patches
patches is handed through the handles as
a list so I have a red patch and a blue
patch cuz I have red and red and blue um
colors here so so I'm just going to run
all
that and so so far I've created a plot
that looks like what I did here with a
whole lot less work right I mean a whole
lot more work to get essentially a plot
that hasn't shown me anything more but
as we go you'll see an ad Morse
Aesthetics but you see there's a problem
here now notice at certain mileages and
at certain price ranges like at 19 m per
gallon and 24 26 look at how many dots
are piled on top of each other we call
this
overplotting and you can't um feel like
we missed a an exercise oh well um you
can't really tell how many cars are in
that pile up so to speak right so
transparency doesn't really add another
dimension but it lets us look through
and it's pretty easy to add there's just
an alpha argument and that's true of
almost all pandas plotting a matte plot
you know Bas mat plot Li um pandas
plotting um caborn whatever the the
argument is called Alpha so three mean
zero
transparency it's actually seethrough so
zero means it's invisible right you
you've it there has no color at all one
is the default that's totally opaque dot
so 3 is about you know 3/10 of the way
from Opa from transparent so that's the
only change in this
code and if I scroll down here oh by the
way here's my patches I don't know if I
showed you that before and now I can
start to see you know you can see yeah
there's some overplotted points here and
some single you know you get a better
feel for like pretty high density in
certain places like here where there's
just a lot of cars with similar
characteristics on this plot in other
places not so much they're just sort of
happen to line up okay so here's here's
an exercise for you guys um create a new
code cell you know just insert a cell
below copy the code from above and
change the color
choice and
um and and also we're going to do engine
size versus curb weight so we're going
to change that list of columns we subset
and see what you come up with okay and
I'm going to go ahead and do it here too
because I got
this
oops and if anybody's like stuck wave
and Ronald can help
you
see if
I I'm just going to call mine autocolor
to so I don't overwrite my
function
oh I'm sorry I meant to say yeah so you
can see see there's a for Loop here I
forgot to mention that so that for Loop
lets you Loop over a list of columns so
you'll get a couple of um plots just one
on top of you know one after the
other so you just replace this Loop list
with
that and then I don't
know
see did I succeed what else did I do
this if you're getting stuck raise your
hand and Ronald can help
you okay I think I did it see what
happens
yeah
okay
good
yeah
I the stickers in your computer so I'm
just wondering so in our
Jitter you can
J actually yeah
like seor has some nice jit stuff buil
actually a lot of I think a lot of
Seaborn they were trying to reproduce
some of the more advanced features of
art
graphics and and it it works in many
cases I'm not sure it works in every
case it would yeah but just knowing that
that's the
analogy helpful oh okay
well
yeah
yeah thought
only
s
on
All
rights all right so it looks like a
number of you are finished and some are
still working but you'll have time to do
this later as well um just to stick to
our 90minut time frame here we got to
move on um since I'm also chairing this
session I suppose I get demerits if I
run too far over um so here's my
solution all I did was I changed um what
was dark blue to green and I changed it
on the patch and I just put this list of
columns here so really wasn't that many
things of course you know I have the
advantage I wrote the code so I know
what I know what's where I didn't have
to reverse engineer what I was doing um
but but what I want to call you the
reason I want you guys to do this partly
is you start to see from different views
different aspects of the data set and
this is true of any data set so but in
this particular case like if we look at
engine size versus price it's not too
actually surprising you know cars with
big engines tend to be big cars the cost
more right so it's it's pretty linear
relationship there honestly right except
for a few we got a few odd outliers at
the low end oops sorry and at the high
end which we don't know about but
generally yeah big you pay more for
bigger engines and notice the diesel are
kind of all just in there right so it
doesn't look like how much you pay for
the size of the engine matters between
gasoline and Diesel so that's that's
interesting now if we look at
this is price versus curb weight we
start to get some odd things we've got
generally heavy cars cost more it me
probably makes more sense there's just
more materials probably more labor Etc
but we've got a couple of very costly
lightweight cars here so that's
interesting we've
got and and even if you sort of think
about what the straight line is we've
got again some very even for heavy car
there's some what seem like anomalously
expensive cars out here so we could we
could continue to investigate that you
know what we could subset our pandas
data frame for cars with a price over
30,000 maybe just look at you know what
are those cars what's special about them
and then you know same thing down here
maybe for extremely light cars we can
just look at them see what they are so
okay so one of the reasons to go through
all this extra code is as I said you
can't separate marker at least maybe
somebody will come and show me oh I
wanted to mention something sorry so
there was a question while you guys were
working on the exercise about the
relationship between some of the plots
I'm showing here and plots in R so if
you don't know anything about R plotting
this isn't going to help you but part of
what they're trying to do with Seaborn
is bring into the pandas world or into
the python World some of the more
Cutting Edge plotting methods in R like
the violin plots and stuff like that so
if you know a bit about R plotting maybe
that helps you think about it if you
don't know anything about our plotting
ignore that I just said that so because
it is going to help you or hurt you um
so let's add a another a marker size so
there's this s argument in the Panda's
data frame and one of the things you got
to think about so we're going to do
we're going to make the marker
size we're going to set it by the engine
size of the car okay we're going to add
another dimension to our plot so we're
actually going to have four dimensions
here we're going to have the whatever
the column is City miles per gallon this
place the price that's two then we're
going to have the color for gas or
diesel that's three and we're going to
have the marker size be a fourth
dimension so we're going to have four
dimensions on this plot and notice I had
to scale this a little bit like by 0.
five um and Alpha as you'll see Al
having the alpha set fairly low when you
do larger U markers is often very
important because by having big markers
you're tending to get more
overplotting so here we
go
and so you can see some diesel it
doesn't you know you can see a couple
cars here with bigger engine smaller
engines you know I stared at this
surprisingly a larger engine and a
smaller engine you know the biggest
engines tend to be up here I think um in
these expensive low efficiency cars
which you know shouldn't be too
surprising but notice there's an issue
here this is the the engine size here is
plotted as the diameter or radius or
whatever of the marker right right and
that's it our eyes I think and there's
been research on this the human eye
isn't that good at noticing that small
differences in diameter you know you got
to kind of really look and say oh yeah
yeah that that engine is a little
smaller than that engine right you know
but it's not so great so another way to
do this is what I've done
here where
um well it's off the off the screen here
but I basically squared it so I'm going
by the so so now the area of my marker
is proportional to engine size rather
than the like the radius or whatever
okay and so let me run
that and you can see you
know yeah look I mean that was that
relationship you could hardly see before
but you can see yeah this this car
definitely has an engine that's quite a
bit bigger than that car for example um
you know with using an area marker size
as opposed to a SI a size marker size is
often a really powerful technique to
keep in mind and there's a lot of
research has been done on the human
perception issues of these kind of
things what's misleading by the way
you'll notice in my presentation there
are no pie charts um
Tuki who I keep talking about had a br
there's a in if you read that 1977
bookie he he he doesn't talk about pie
charts he has one little foot note
basically that says pie charts are are
an excellent tool for off you skating
the relationships in your data so
basically if you're trying to fool
people use lots of pie charts if you're
trying to elucidate and illuminate your
observations don't use pie charts so so
another thing we can do now so let's
bring a
Fifth Dimension onto this
plot and we're going to use marker shap
AP and um so this gets a little
complicated the code here I'm sorry so I
had I built four
lists because I'm going to do four
subsets so I'm going to have aspiration
of Turbo and diesel turbo and gas
standard and Diesel standard and gas so
those are my four possible combinations
of you know how the carburation and the
fuel type right and then I I'm going to
use a a DOT you know a an O for Turbo
and a plus for
standard and then I'm going to use red
for diesel so you see diesel is red dark
blue for gas diesel is red dark blue for
gas is that I hope that's clear I mean
it's it's just this is just setting it
up but you know you have to somehow
Define all this stuff so I just did it
as four lists
and um again we're going to just do it
on one axis
here and then I just loop I just use I
zip you guys know about zip I hope so I
just zip all four of those lists
together and in my for loop I get you
know an element from each of those four
lists that I can use down here to to lay
basically I'm laying four layers on top
of that plot um the first being you know
the turbo diesel then the turbo gas Etc
so a little tricky but not too bad if
you think about it so let me run that um
code hopefully it's not too mindboggling
all right so now we've got a
five-dimensional plot on our
two-dimensional surface we've got price
on the vertical City miles per gallon on
the horizontal we've
got gas and blue turbo or diesel in in
red and then we've got um standard
aspiration with pluses and turbo cars in
circles so you can see for example all
our big outlier cars here are gas
standard aspiration
cars and and they all have big engine
sizes for the most part so that's why
they're expensive and why they are gas
fuel guzzlers basically right um notice
that most of our diesels are
turbo see they're most most of the red
on here is circles very few non-turbo
diesels um and we do have some odd
things like the big gas engine down here
that's yet very fuel efficient and
things like that but you know which we'd
have to investigate further those seem
to be just odd relationships but so I
hope you guys see now I've how I've it's
it's a bit of code admittedly but you
know we've gotten five Dimensions onto
this plot and we've learned some
interesting stuff uh by doing that
okay and so some plot specific
um Aesthetics the simplest one is like
histograms how many bins so I'm just
going to make oh and so the the only new
thing you got to know here is notice how
I did plot. subplots one 2 and in a
figure size so that means one row two
columns so I'm creating a little array
of axes so you see how I have axis zero
axis one down
here so let me just run
that and the only point of this is you
know the default was 10 we saw that
before if I use 40 it looks a lot Jagger
but I can see like well there's really
just three cars out here in this really
big engine category or there's really
just two cars in these outliers of low
engine size so there's quite you know
but again it depends what you're trying
to present what you're trying to look at
whether you know there's no saying that
more bins are better it's just
different um and we can do a similar
thing with like um violin plots going
back to Seaborn so we have a hue
parameter and we're going to make that
aspiration remember remember we did auto
price and fuel type to do two side
by-side violin plots before so now I've
added
Hue and I'm also going to split I have
this split argument
set and so now you see oops well if I
scroll correctly you'll see
ah sorry so you'll
see gas cars that are turbo and
standard and diesel cars that are turbo
and standard so you start to see there's
real differences in the price
distributions of these cars so we've got
three dimensions on this surface here
because we have fuel type aspiration and
price so um and you can do similar
things with box plots
in
um so notice I got the gas and the
diesel I did this by body style so you
can see like hard tops have this really
wide price range and almost all hard
tops are gas I think that might be one
hard top that's diesel you kind of have
to investigate these ones that are just
a single bar don't look like
anything okay so um another exercise
we'll do this hopefully really quick um
because I want to get on to multiaxis
plots before we run out of
time so do another so code cell and just
change the it's really just changing
that violin plot and looking instead of
um where we did um
um let's see which gas and Diesel we're
going to do um wheel drive wheel so it's
like rear wheel drive front-wheel drive
four-wheel drive okay so try that for
just a couple
minutes hopefully you're still with me
me we'll
see harder than it
looks see if I do this
correctly so there's really one just one
thing you have to change for this
exercise it's very
quick that's
pretty yeah
I
so with luck yall should be getting
something like this more or
less J not pretty shaky Podium
here
okay
this
hang
on okay it looks like a number of people
seem to be done um
so really all you had to do was change
this x variable to drive
Wheels because you're just trying to put
the type of Drive wheel which is a
categorical variable on this
xaxis and you can see yeah there's
significant difference between standard
and turbo aspiration for rear wheeel
drive front-wheel drive four-wheel drive
for example our cheapest cars are all
standard aspiration
front-wheel drive cars yeah it kind of
makes sense right I mean what do your
small light inexpensive cars tend to be
front-wheel drive cars your outliers in
terms of really expensive cars tend to
be again these gasoline standard
aspiration cars so you know if you know
even a tiny bit about cars that all make
sense all right so let's sorry we got to
move on here but um so another thing
we're going to look at now so we've
basically been dealing with one axis
with one exception in in your exercise
way up here um you created two axes one
after the other but you didn't plot on
them but let's look at what we can do if
we do different axes on a single figure
so this is another way to um add extra
Dimensions to a visualization it's a
very important thing and I mentioned the
book by Bill Cleveland at the beginning
so this was a lot of the thinking behind
this in the 80s and early 90s was done
by Bill Cleveland to think about how do
we come up with ways to use multiple
axis on a plot figure to Show additional
dimensions and Show additional
information
so um so a simple
one oops let me go back up
here so we can just
do so like there's a there's three types
I'd like to get through here or four
types so there's a pair
plot there's pairwise Scatter Plots
multi-axis plots and faceted grids so
try to get through this um so there's a
thing called a joint plot in Seaborn and
let me just show you what it is so we've
got two Dimensions defined here engine
size and price and our data is auto
prices so what does that look like it's
actually kind of cool so it's and you
can do other things you could I think
you can add a hue to this as well but
basically we have
our price versus engine size and you see
the densities in terms of histograms on
the margins of the plot right so nothing
I don't think there's anything here we
haven't noticed with another plot type
but it's another way to display and if
you had many pairwise combinations to go
through it could be a cool way to do
it but there's also a pairwise scatter
plot capability called pair plot in
caborn so I'm just going to do the
numeric columns you can you can include
or certain numeric columns you can
include categorical variables but
they'll just show up as lines of dots
you know horizontally vertically
whatever
and um oh well you guys can't see well
maybe I can do this here yeah okay so so
so I have Auto prices I just subset by
this list of numeric columns I'm going
to set the Hue to fuel type which is
what we've been doing my same pallet and
then I can say what the on the diagonal
I'm going to do a kernel density plot
and then on the upper see there's also
this method map. s upper I'm going to do
a kernel density plot as well and I'm
again use that blue Blues underbar D
palette so this going to take a while to
compute
this it's just going to grind
Away by the way depending on versions
and things like that I I Ronald doesn't
get this I do this warning it's coming I
think it's actually maybe a bug in a
newer version of numpy that things that
are integers somehow it doesn't think
they're integers or something it doesn't
seem to hurt anything um but it's it's a
bit
annoying um okay so there's a lot going
on here so you see the general idea of a
pairwise scatter plot is we've got like
price versus length price versus curb
weight price versus engineer size
horsepower City and then you can see
because we've got turbo and standard so
here's the the two density plots the
kdes
of of price for the two kinds of cars
and you can see you know you can look at
like curb weight
versus um length and you know not too
surprisingly long cars tend to be heavy
CU they're they're big right and then
this is the two-dimensional KDE so again
you can see length and Cur curb weight
you can you know it's the same
relationship but you can see there's
actually two
centroids where cars tend to be light
short cars or long heavy cars there's
not that there's kind of a gap in
between those two big bumps I you know
who knows why it's just maybe how car
manufacturers do it and you can see this
is a relationship we looked at before of
um oh wait a minute which one was I
going to show you it was the
um let's see I was looking for price and
engine size well you can see it here
like horsepower and price let's just go
with that one and there was this
question about you can see the def fault
here is to show those outliers that are
beyond beyond where the lowest Contour
is you can see the little green dots
there so again most of our cars tend to
be cheap low horsepower cars but there's
a few expensive High horsepower cars
that just lie out by themselves there so
you can study this plot for a long time
you know there's lots of information
here as you can see many this is a multi
view plot I call it because there's just
a lot going on there um
and so that's one way to do it another
we thing we can do here
is this is similar to what I've been
showing you
but we
can um create a plot so in this case
remember I I did this before where we
have the axes and the figures and this
is going to create a 2X two array of
axes on a 12 by 12 sized figure okay is
that I hope that's clear and I have to
Define what the X columns are and the Y
columns and I'm just going to actually I
want the unique
values and then I'm going to enumerate
over those unique values because I'm
going to subset the data and plot the
histograms
so hopefully that's not too much cryptic
code and this is kind
of so you can see I've got the histogram
of price with
aspiration equals standard and fuel type
equals gas so I've subset it it's you
know basically I've done a a manual kind
of group by just using the subsetting
capabilities in pan
here so I've see I've got two conditions
with an and in the middle right and
that's that's how I
subset
and and then i' I plot the histogram see
dotplot doist of that
subset and you know and then this one
down here is aspiration equals tural
fuel type equals diesel notice there's
not main thing you come away from that
is notice there's no there's very few of
these and they're pretty much just
uniformly distributed there isn't the
only one with a clear distribution is
this first one where they're all sort of
bunched up at the low end of um
price so all our low it looks like our
lowcost cars are all
gasoline standard aspiration cars that's
kind of the takeaway message there now I
can do another thing with Seaborn which
is very cool and this is what the sort
of the the key thing that that Cleveland
book had I can create what's called a
facet
grid and a facet grid is is I've done
this manually this is a way to do it so
I'm creating a group by variable here
for the columns called Drive wheels and
I'm going to do a an XY plot of engine
size and price using the rig so I have
to say what my plot method is
here and oh and I'm not going to show
the regression line I could do that if I
remove that but so I just get three
Scatter Plots and you see it says Drive
Wheels equals rear wheeel drive drive
Wheels equals front-wheel drive drive
Wheels equals four-wheel drive and I got
price versus engine size so side by side
here I can look at the price engine size
relationship of cars by how many what
type of Drive Wheels they have and and I
can extend that now here so I've got so
here I do columns or drive wheels and
rows or body style so this starts to
show you the real magic
here I hope so so now I've got
four-dimensional PL because I've got
price and engine size on each of these
plots and then I've got body style going
down and drive Wheels going across so
I've got I think
15 little Scatter Plots that I've subset
my data into and I can start trying to
study it notice some of these may be
empty like there's no four-wheel drive
hard tops for example there's just no
data there so it just shows a blank grid
um or there's just one um four-wheel
drive Hatchback for example but so so so
you know to this is a small data set if
you had a large data set you might see a
lot more um but we only have 195 cars in
this data set but I hope you guys are
seeing how this is pulling out four
dimensions onto a single 2D plot surface
now and then I'm going to do one more
thing I'm going to add an aesthetic
which is fuel
type to my grid you
see and now we can see occasionally here
we see where there's
diesels so all
right so here's your last exercise and
we're kind of at the end of our time but
we can take a couple minutes here while
we pack up um so give that a try change
the X variable to City miles per
gallon and so you're just going to
change that facet grid definition and
see how far you
get
for
oops did I hit
it
h no I guess it's
running is the colonel
running I think my
Colonel so again if you have
trouble let us know
uhoh Ro what did I
do
the
point oh I goof I copied the wrong thing
here
yeah oh yeah you're
right yeah
thanks
all I sometimes get um what do you call
it
um language schizophrenia cuz the U
Washington data science program we've
standardized on
R not that it's better or worse than
python it's just you have to standardize
on something
so so some days of the week I'm in the
python world and some days in the r
world so you can see anyway if you do
this you see you get this pretty
complicated plot that you can scan and
study and try to figure out you know
some interesting cool stuff
um actually I'm doing a violin plot that
isn't quite what I want it to have
anyway hm okay looks good though yeah it
looks cool but um that's not the point
of the exercise I must have cut and
pasted the wrong
thing let me try that
again
well if you have any questions let us
know thanks everyone for attending I
hope that was worth your 90 minutes and
um there's lots more cool stuff coming
there's more there's another whole set
of tutorials after this in three
different rooms and um there's two days
of great talks coming
up and thanks to Ron Ronald who's helped
me a lot hey
Ronald